lima
welcome back thank you mark so you've
become an expert on how to
help people you did such a great job
with amanda
um you've also helped some other people
you're trying to help your sisters who
are in a similar situation that amanda
was in kind of
share what you what information you've
learned about how to help people because
i think there's probably a lot of
families
friends
that would love to help some of the
people that are dealing with mental
illness and drug addiction
yeah i think the biggest factor is
being able to spot signs early my
essentially downfall with my family was
we weren't really educated in mental
health early on so my sisters had little
symptoms here and there and instead of
coming to myself or my mom or instead of
us being able to really see it
they went to a mental health
professional and became addicted to the
medications that they were prescribed
and they were essentially misdiagnosed
what kind of childhood did you guys go
through
you know our father was very abusive and
when i say abusive in a sense
this is something that we brushed over
when i first came on your channel i
didn't really go into detail because it
makes me really uncomfortable to talk
about but i think it is important to put
it out there
you know we would wake up if we woke up
before him he would duct tape us to
chairs and duct tape our mouth shut
and
there was a lot of violence in the
household and so
growing up
we never like hugged each other or
kissed each other or said i love you
like we weren't very affectionate to
each other
and
when my mom left my dad i was
essentially the protector of my sisters
and you know
the weird situation that i'm in with
with where my sisters are and this
mental health
industry that's kind of fallen apart in
our you know across not just america but
worldwide
is
um
you know
i'm in a place where if i could just let
go of being the protector of my sisters
and if i could just let go
of wanting to help them i could have a
really great life and the issue is
the way that
we see mental health is oh somebody's
using in your household if they're doing
drugs in your household kick them out
like you know you need to
disown family members when they've gone
too far at some point they're going to
take you down and there is a point where
that is true you can't enable them to a
point where they're destroying their
lives in your life but
you know i feel that
i'm essentially a symbol that you don't
give up on people like there is no
reason to
give up on people and tell me about your
sisters they were
they're they're opiate addicts
no my sisters are addicted to
benzodiazepines
which is like xanax and kalonopin they
also have an addiction to adderall
and
ultimately
it's the mental health factor that
they're really struggling with so they
were misdiagnosed as schizophrenic for
three years and then they were properly
diagnosed after that with dissociative
identity disorder it can't be treated
with
it can be treated with medications only
specialized therapy and so the fact that
they're using adderall and benzos which
are their prescriptions
they can't do the therapy to get them to
where they need to be
also our system is entirely dependent on
medications because we don't have the
bandwidth with all of the mental health
professionals there's not enough mental
health professionals to treat the number
of patients that need help there's not
enough psychiatric beds to get people in
when you know they need to exit their
environment and be in like a
rehabilitation facility so the system um
you know the factor with insurance
companies they won't pay for more than
30 days sometimes even only just two
weeks
for a person to just detox and get out
and
it just creates this massive
situation where people don't have access
to actual help so we sedate them with
medications and
i've said this in other interviews
before i'm definitely not against
medications
i work in software i have a software
company and
i'm all about using medications with
therapy like let's not exclude the fact
that a lot of these people
need help and if you look at the people
that come on your channel they're in
immense pain like they've gone through
a tremendous struggle
and they've let that struggle bury them
and like the situation with my sisters
and i we came from the same abusive
house referring to the drug addicted or
the mentally ill because yeah because
i've branched out and i'm interviewing
yes
so that's not to say everyone not
everyone but but the people that you've
interviewed that struggle severely with
addiction homelessness mental health
issues
you know they they have a lot of pain
and
my myself and my sisters same thing you
know i don't think anyone
like you know this life is really just a
test and no one can go through life
without any pain or emotion some people
just process it better and coming from
the same household as my sisters
you know i took that pain and i found
purpose in it and i took my role as my
sister's protector
and
i
you know learned how to navigate the
system to help them and my purpose for
coming on your channel was essentially
to teach other people how to navigate
the system what community resources are
out there to help their loved ones and
also
to really push change in the industry
and the only way that that can be done
is if insurance companies who are
financing
you know people getting better with
healthcare to start seeing the industry
differently and i'm too small as one
person for them to listen to me but if
we all get together and we really demand
change and we demand that insurance
companies start treating mental health
like physical health that's where we
really completely
give the industry a facelift and you'll
actually see homelessness starting to
shift and you'll see people actually
healing and you won't have this blanket
mentality of
oh that person's a drug addict it's too
late for them just give up on them
i think the best example i can give is
cancer treatment typically cost
insurance companies a hundred and fifty
thousand dollars
that's the average
if you look at kidney transplants it
costs about four hundred just over four
hundred thousand dollars
for someone to get a heart transplant it
costs upwards of
a mill 1 million or 1.5 million dollars
people wouldn't just cash pay that
insurance companies pay for it because
they know that this is a physical
illness
if we make this payment the physical
illness will improve the problem with
mental health is
you're going to give me
you know you're telling me to pay on
average about 45 000 per month per
person
but there's a 90 failure rate when it
comes to alcohol and opioid addiction so
they're relapsing and they end up back
in these situations
insurance companies are just looking to
save money because they are businesses
and the only way to appeal to these
businesses that are paying the bills is
to show them that there's a way to spend
a little bit more now
and save money in the long run and
that's essentially what my whole brand
is for it's to appease to the insurance
companies to start taking their role and
shifting it
and you know actually
helping people get better so yes they'll
spend a little bit more now
and in the long run they'll save
billions of dollars
and
again with my sisters this started nine
years ago for us
when they started having mental health
issues
and
today nine years later insurance
companies have spent about 2.5 million
on each of my sisters to keep them sick
for the nine-year period with all of the
relapses and re-hospitalizations and
everything
if they had spent 500 000 or less on one
year of treatment
then
you know it would have been a massive
savings for them and my sisters would be
doing a lot better what you did with
amanda
and some other people his work so
effective works so effectively what are
you doing with your sister are you able
to do the same thing with your sisters
no because i can't afford to to pay 90
000 a month and my entire push has been
for me to get insurance companies to
care
about
what i'm doing and see that i can help
the worst cases
and get insurance companies if i can get
the insurance company to pay for
long-term treatment for my sisters the
one year forty five thousand a month
that they see that they're going to
actually heal which is what they see
with physical illnesses you pay for this
and you heal
right
that's
that's where everything shifts and
that's the reason that i haven't been
able to help my sisters
so right now
my mom is their full-time caretaker
and
i'm
you know my husband and i are
financially responsible we pay for
their
their health care coverage we pay for
doctor's appointments we pay for their
housing
but we can't afford to pay
for actual treatment if insurance won't
pay for it and so your company aura
helps therapists
interpret
their patients reactions right basically
yeah so it just tracks which patients
are at highest risk and which patients
are at lowest risk
and um
our goal is really to see how the
patient is feeling and treat physical
mental health like physical health they
might be saying
oh i feel fine but exactly their
emotions could be reading something
absolutely and look at um
look at day 28 of amanda in treatment
she was talking about how she was
craving the entire time
she
doesn't regret her old life she would
have easily gone back so if we depended
on insurance we were cash paying
if we
two to in two days from that interview
she would have been released because
by insurance standards she was detoxed
because she they only look at the
physical aspect what drug were you
taking
let's get it out of your system but they
don't look at the reason that you're
abusing drugs and so she had a lot of
trauma the only way for her to
[Music]
like not relapse is to work through that
trauma and you can't just openly talk
about it immediately you really need to
get to a point where you build trust
with the therapist you are able to like
one of the biggest things is
amanda didn't have any value of herself
she got treated
just like horrifically on the street
and
she just her self-worth was at like a
negative and
when you have someone in treatment for a
longer period of time the first thing
that they do is they want to see what
you're like with no medication
so that's what your baseline is that's
how they kind of look at where you're
presenting and
you know amanda had been in treatment
prior and she was misdiagnosed several
times she had a bunch of different
diagnoses because she was on hold for
like three days two days
um she had a diagnosis of schizophrenia
which when she went into the treatment
center and she had a longer period of
time they were looking at her baseline
like she doesn't have schizophrenia
the schizophrenia was drug induced
these are all details that prior i was
hesitant to give out but since
her medical information has been shared
all over the internet which is
unfortunate
um you know it's it's public information
now yeah
and then the reason you
got it is it a conservatorship or a
guardianship no i didn't get um
so originally when we were trying to
figure out who we were going to help and
we were letting the voters the people
the audience vote for who they wanted
um
they picked amanda and then i was
looking at okay well you told me amanda
has zero desire to get better
and she was also when i met her
she was already in jail so
what we were trying to do was file
what's called an lps conservatorship
it's the equivalent of a guardianship in
um
you know
in the in the grand understanding it's
that
conservatorships that deal with the
estate and the person's mental health
are called probate conservatorships in
la and guardianships per se are called
lps conservatorships in in california
this in l.a and california
and so
we attempted to file an lps
conservatorship but amanda's public
defender was overwhelmed with how many
cases he had so he never filed the
documentation
and so essentially we just applied to
the court for a court order so amanda
was never under guardianship she was
never under conservatorship
she
she didn't have
any type of like healthcare directive
agent or anything like that she just had
the court telling her like
you need to go she had
attacked her father which was a felony
because he she attacked him with a
weapon
and they were looking at either
jail time for her and so i just
petitioned like this is not a criminal
situation it's a mental health situation
um
so we essentially just asked the judge
if um we cash paid her treatment and got
got her out of the system so she's not a
burden on the system
would he be willing to court order
treatment instead of jail time yeah you
were flying down from seattle where you
lived at the time
like twice three times a week sometimes
right yeah and i was paying for all of
my own trips and the gofundme that we
were raising was for
a nonprofit giving.org which was
collecting the funds to pay for her
medical bills didn't generate much money
though
it didn't uh it brought in
well when i first announced it it
brought in 1 500
so definitely not what what we were
expecting
and
by then i had already started working on
amanda's case and petitioned for
treatment over punishment and then
we had set her up in a treatment center
in los angeles and they were demanding
that she that they get paid or they're
gonna release her if they release amanda
because they didn't get paid then um
she would have ended up in jail because
it would have been a violation of her
court order she had to stay in the rehab
yeah so i made a an impulsive decision
to take out a massive loan believing
that if i could show that amanda was
gonna get better that people would start
supporting the gofundme to so i could
get reimbursed for my payments
and um
you know i paid for her treatment
with the loan it was a
large amount yeah and then the and then
200 000
to 250 000 and i got back
um
seven thousand so our last video that we
did with amanda
they'll go three seven thousand from the
gofundme yes so the gofundme uh
originally raised one thousand five
hundred
then you know her second interview where
she didn't seem like she was doing much
better day 28 in treatment
that that obviously everyone was like oh
you can't help her she doesn't want to
get better leave her alone and then her
interview at i think 189 days
um everyone was just in awe of how much
better she had gotten that the gofundme
went from
1500 to 37 000 and so giving so i
prepaid for her treatment so giving
would pay directly to the treatment
centers and the treatment center was
supposed to refund me whatever i had
already paid for so that i never
actually touched
donor funds especially since i have a
software company and it would be a
conflict of interest so i made sure to
always separate amanda's transformation
was so remarkable when that last time i
saw her
which is shortly before she passed away
was i didn't even recognize her i'm
standing there talking to her and think
this is the same person that i used to
see on skid row yeah she was so alert so
cogent
yeah she looked and acted and spoke
differently
absolutely
i mean it's still really hard to talk
about
because
i'm very close to larry and he's he's in
a lot of pain and as i'm sure
some of the viewers know that there's
been a lot of misinformation spread
about amanda about larry about myself
and you of just people kind of trying to
make entertainment out of the situation
taking people's pain and turning it into
like views and clicks well they take a
lot of information out of context yeah
they make up some information and create
a sensational video that makes it look
like
yeah like you're up to no good or
somebody's up to no good or larry was
molesting his daughter which amanda did
say at one point when she that very very
first interview but she straightened
that out later when she was cogent and
sober as a judge
that she was just saying that just
because she said that about everybody i
mean i i interviewed amanda maybe a
hundred more than a hundred times you
only see about
eight or nine of them on this channel
but
she would say oh he's a molester he's
you know she would say that all the time
about everyone and also um
when amanda so
when amanda started getting to a place
where she was doing better
she she was calling me every day just to
check up on me and you know we were
friends like we we had a really close
relationship
and when she got to a point where she
actually watched her videos with you
um
she was mortified about what she had
said about larry um and this is
she has said it to me at least on three
separate occasions where when can i
shoot with mark when can i shoot with
mark i really want to straighten out
what i said about my dad um she was
calling her dad like you know three to
five six times a day he she constantly
said he's her best friend
um
and
a lot of these
one person in particular you know
who appears to have a history of doing
this to people
uh basically
created a story with a false narrative
and pushed it out and unfortunately like
there have been proven studies that bad
news gets more views than good news and
so creating some crazy conspiracy
where you know
the courts are rigged and the doctors
and
everybody's in on this like insane um
hollywood like little plot is just um
so insulting to the entire situation
especially the fact that we
you know before people want to make
stories up about me i would really urge
that they come to skid row or that they
go to their community and go volunteer
and try to help people i think that
you know
it would be a very humbling experience
because what i what i do is really
difficult what you do is really
difficult
when you look at therapists
a lot of them
are very much affected by the people
that they treat because they're
listening to these painful stories and
the worst part about it is
when insurance cuts off
and the therapists who have no say in
keeping the patients in treatment that
have built a relationship are like
heartbroken that this person they know
is going to go out there and relapse and
harm themselves but they can't keep them
into in the treatment center so
this industry is full of people that
actually care there's better ways to
make money than
you know dealing with pain day after day
dealing with tragedy dealing with you
know suicide threats or people going
missing or someone's going to harm
themselves or somebody just overdosed
you know like i always encourage
everyone around me to carry narcon on
them all the time because like
you know the environments that we're
constantly in is
someone someone had an overdose that
something happened like it's constantly
like you're on the battlefield dealing
with tragedy and i think you know i was
expecting to come on your channel and
talk about like a new way uniting
together treating mental health
differently and i kind of found myself
like battling an invisible war with
people that have leaked my private
information they have relentlessly
targeted me
caught shared my
you know home address we just had to
relocate because the attacks have gotten
so bad um my phone number so like they
can call me and yell at me at random
times of the day i don't know it's
really it really got out of yeah
i mean it's a shame because so much of
you you're
it's like you're a crusader almost for
helping these people like whether it's
amanda who tragically passed away but
but at the end amanda was
as sober as you and i are right now and
and she said some of the sweetest things
about you and she said to me privately
that you
you saved your life
and larry said the same thing
many times since since amanda passed
away but
it's a shame because you're helping
people like
chris the schizophrenic
man that i the young man that i
interviewed
yeah whether you want to
find somebody else from my
my channel that you wanted to help you
know rebecca would be a good
yeah we rebecca has a very close place
in my heart
and i think
bam margera as well
yeah
so um
actually with uh chris
what's going on with chris
i brought larry on uh to work with me so
um he's been going to court
you know
so chris chris
the schizophrenic young man i
interviewed he got arrested for
trying to rob a
dispensary i think
uh there was a robbery and they called
it an armed robbery so
um
what initially happened was
uh
i don't know if it was a dispensary or
what the exact details of the case were
but i do know that he had a knife on him
he had stolen some items
when he was leaving he pulled out a
knife
pointed it at an officer and ran
obviously he got caught he didn't harm
anyone or attack anyone but they're
calling it an armed robbery and they
want him to do prison time
and i told larry
this because you had contacted me and
told me what was going on
um so i called larry because
one of amanda's
biggest things was
her vision was that she was gonna go to
school to be a certified nursing
assistant and get larry off of skid row
she wanted to get a two bedroom
for for the two of them
and so originally amanda was supposed to
work with me i was going to hire her
while she was in school so instead
i brought larry on board and so larry's
been going to court with me to help
chris
and essentially we're doing the same
thing we did with amanda which is
petition the court ask them for no jail
time but instead
you know treatment and so we found
the judge is very open to doing
treatment with chris
the issue is number one the payment
factor i can't cash pay for chris
so i'm trying to figure out if there's a
way that i can push him through a
diversion program that already exists
it's just a really tricky situation um
and the scandal
that kind of came out of all these
social media
problems yeah yes
yeah
social media people has made it harder
for you to do anything absolutely
because when people look me up um they
see these crazy accusations and they
don't really do further research so it
really like so giant holes rebecca
whoever else you might help pays the
price yeah absolutely
not to mention all the stress on you and
originally we started the brain rescue
supplements the aura brain rescue
supplements uh so that we could use the
financing from that to pay for people's
treatment to
you know get better housing for
veterans and all of that
and so
i've since since the scandal broke out
i've refunded all of the supplements
because i had people emailing me saying
you know i don't want to support your
scam i want my money back and so
just to you know push down any type of
confusion i've refunded all of the um
the supplement
orders and i've um i've been handling
that as like complementary shipments um
just so that people actually can build
trust with me again and um
you know we got larry a new place i was
really excited to share that but right
now i'm kind of in a weird financial
situation so i haven't posted the video
about his new place because i'm not sure
if i can still make payments on it
um
and uh we did bring larry on but i've
also had to let a few people from my
team go
um yeah these people are claiming you
killed amanda things like that i mean
yeah why would you have gotten a loan
for 250 000 to help her i'm still paying
back the loan that i got like i'm still
paying back the loan that i got i've had
to refund all of my orders for the
supplements i had to pay for the
supplements because they're out an
actual product that i did
i've never seen anyone work as hard as
you did to help amanda when you were
when she was going through the court
process and and getting into rehab and
then
finding a rehab that was more affordable
and just all the work that you did it
was unbelievable
yeah and i um
i
ivan my husband always says no good deed
goes unpunished and i get so mad at him
for saying that but
um i really want to outline to people
that
you know my husband works very hard if i
wanted to like not anyone can just go
and take out a loan for two hundred
thousand you know so i was in a good
financial position where i was able to
do that with my credit um
and
had i wanted to i could have just like
stayed at home gone on vacations
posted on instagram like bikini pictures
and
you know if i was actually like looking
for fame or looking to entertain people
or
just wanted a happy pleasant life but
that would require me
saying that i'm okay with my sisters
being sick and i've given up on them and
so even though i could have a very
relaxing life i've put my husband and i
in a very
negative financial situation i've spent
more money on the business than i've
made a lot of people think oh you have a
small business you must be rich you know
but
last year the money that we made i spent
twice as much because i do have payroll
developers are very expensive hiring
people is very expensive
we survive the covet pandemic without
having to let anyone go
and then all of a sudden we get hit with
you know these false allegations and
these rumors just spreading like
wildfires is your reputation which means
i can't raise money from investors
because when they look me up they're
like red flag don't want to touch it um
i can't make money because these people
have called my
treatment centers that i work with and
basically said
if you work with lima we're gonna
you know
go and make videos about you guys and
all of that so i've put all of my
operations for treatment centers on hold
i've refunded the brain rescue so
they've prevented me from making money
and they've prevented me from raising
money and already as a female founder
in the tech space you know we talked
about this in an earlier attack less
than an earlier talk less than two
percent of
venture capital funding goes to
women-owned businesses so
aside from that little tiny fraction
that i could possibly
appeal to
now all of a sudden like my name and
reputation is tarnished and then on top
of that it's my husband's last name and
um
sorry it's just like really hurts
somebody that
you know has supported me
day in and day out with my sisters
helped me pay for my sisters i've never
taken a paycheck from my own business
because i'd rather put the money back in
the business and hire more people to
help me
and so the only reason i can afford to
do that is because of my husband
supporting me
and then like to see that you know
his last name my our last name is being
dragged through the mud and people are
trying to make up these awful stories
about how i would you know
murder
a dear dear friend like i consider
amanda and larry like family that's the
i think i think a lot of the problems
stemmed from
the autopsy results yeah the autopsy
results came you read them but tell me
about explain what happened with the
autopsy uh yeah well the problems
actually stunned before that they were
making all these conspiracies
it took how many months for them to
so clark county to get the autopsy
um so it took them seven months uh
before they actually gave us an answer
um and so
yeah that's awfully long it was a very
frustrating process because also the
family wanted closure larry wanted
closure i wanted closure and also all of
the donors and the viewers wanted
closure
and so
when they finally came back with an
answer
they said
amanda died from arrhythmia cardiac
arrhythmia relating to schizophrenia and
when we asked
while
she didn't have schizophrenia
you know originally they said because uh
people with schizophrenia have a
four times higher chance of having
cardiac arrhythmia
and so then we responded with you know
amanda didn't have schizophrenia did you
get her medical records from the
treatment center she passed away at
and um
and their response was oh we never
received those medical records um she
was at that treatment center first
for um
so
december january february march april
may
um she was at that facility for six
months and they didn't get her
medical records from the facility she
passed away from um so we responded and
um we sent them videos also the autopsy
report says that amanda didn't have any
type of traumatic brain injury that she
was never
uh you know
and anybody that
had she had more traumatic head injuries
than anyone i've ever seen yeah so even
if you were to examine her um we were i
was also paying for her medic her dental
bills um and so we were trying to
replace her teeth because she had her
teeth knocked out
she had her jaw dislocated
she
just so anyways we sent them all of
these things and upon review
the doctor that performed the autopsy
report
sent me back
you know an email that you also have a
copy of
and um essentially stating that they're
going to amend the autopsy results now
that they have this additional
information that they somehow overlooked
um
and so it made you look bad in the
social media world
and they also knew that i was going to
give a public statement um because they
had all of your videos um and so i read
directly from exactly what the doctor
sent me word for word because i didn't
want to mess it up
and i guess they never amended the
autopsy report so we're waiting for a
response from clark county i'm actually
i've had to
request that they do issue a public
statement because i'm not trying to do
the he said she said thing
i'd rather it come from the source
and you know the other accusation was
amanda had more than just tylenol in her
system
my
you know
statement to that is the fact that i
have never been against medication
and
for me to reveal what medication
somebody's on
is outside of hipaa law and so at the
time prior to everything becoming so
public because of these people seeking
to get medical records and autopsy
results and all of that and posting it
all over the internet against the wishes
of the family and the privacy and
respect for amanda
you know i couldn't list her actual
medications that she was taking because
that would require me actually revealing
what her mental illness diagnosis was
the question was did amanda relapse and
my answer was no she just had tylenol in
her system she was in a treatment center
residential under 24 7 surveillance she
didn't relapse on drugs she stayed sober
she died sober
and i was told that she had tylenol in
her system i guess it was actually
aspirin in her system
and i was just reading exactly what i
was given
so
um
no i think i think some people love to
create a scandal
where maybe there isn't one
absolutely
and they they realize they can get a lot
of views on a video that way and make
some money maybe on youtube and before
people start commenting oh everyone's
saying it so it must be true i really
urge you to do your research because the
people that are making these videos they
have like cash app links in their videos
they have like personal gofundmes
they're monetizing all of these videos
they have a history of doing this to
other people too right they have
histories of doing this to other people
um the main woman that's been attacking
me and kind of leading the witch hunt um
you know
she
to my knowledge is unemployed so she's
just pushing out these videos and
monetizing them and they're getting a
lot of views um she's also like been
sued by her school yeah but they're
unwatchable because once you hear
somebody taking these things out of
context
it just this is ridiculous information i
think i think 99.9 of my audience
is intelligent enough to know the truth
of the situation
but it's that very loud
very
upset little point one percent point
zero one percent that just
makes a million
you know they leave comments on all the
videos about amanda you killed amanda
and all that stuff absolutely and it's
it's it's really heartbreaking
yeah and it doesn't deserve it she loved
everything you did for her
yeah and larry does too
definitely and i i do want to amanda
would be so upset by all of this yeah
all right lima well thank you so much
for
explaining all that thank you mark and
thank you for giving me an opportunity
to voice all of this out and
for everybody watching at home i want
you guys to know that
even though this did slow me down quite
a bit
it hasn't
you know it hasn't shifted my motivation
in any way i'm going to continue
and
you know my goal is to really push the
mental health revolution and change this
so that everybody can have access to
mental health care
you're amazing thank you thank you okay
you